what's going on everybody welcome to
another Python 3 tutorial video in this
video what we're going to be talking
about is the standard library with
Python most importantly here we're going
to be talking about is some of the
built-in functions so these are
functions that you won't actually have
to ever do any imports with so that's
like you know print and stuff like that
by no means are we going to cover them
all I'll put a link in the description
to all of them there's you know the
Python 3 documentation so you can look
through all of them there are some that
are a little bit more advanced than
others but for now I'm just going to
cover some of the more basic ones that I
personally have found to be useful
over the years programming and Python
this video actually we're going to cover
all the ones I want to cover in just one
video and then then we're going to be
talking a little bit more about the
standard library some of the functions
that we can import or modules rather
that we can import so these are just
functions that are just built-in
functions and then there's also built-in
modules that we're going to import and
you know like OS is URL Lib some of
these are really really powerful and not
too many people have very extensive
tutorials on how to use these built-in
modules but you can actually do a lot of
really really cool things with these so
that's what you guys have to look
forward to but for now we're just gonna
be talking about these built-in
functions so let's go ahead and get
started
so here we've got just an empty empty
script we're just going to just run
through them best way I can think of it
is just pretty much to do alphabetical
order
the first one is absolute values so
absolute value is basically you take any
any number in the absolute value of that
number is its distance from zero so
basically you would use absolute value
if you always want a positive number
that's at least how I think of it but in
theory its definition is it's different
as distance from zero but for example we
can say example num1 equals negative
five example number two equals five and
what we can do is we can print the ABS
so abs is that function which stands for
absolute value and we can print abs eggs
num1 and for now let's go ahead and save
and run that see what it looks like
it's just a regular five positive five
so then we can also do a conditional and
ask if these are the same and so we can
say if adds eggs num1 is identical to
eggs num2 print i don't know we could
just say these are the same something
simple like that so we need to save and
run that just to make sure these are
valued as the same and they sure are
obviously so that's the first one just
simple absolute values now the next one
that I want to show you guys I guess for
to start we can actually continue on in
our little interactive interpreter here
and that's the help function this is
probably one of the most underutilized
functions in Python some people in
myself included actually just use Google
so if I want help on a function or like
want to find the documentation on a
function I just typed that function into
Google and I learned about it I just
type the function name and then Python
and Google but there is the help
function and if you put empty parameters
in here it just starts you off almost
basically like a search bar so we could
type in URL Lib for example and we could
get information on URL Lib we could type
in time get information on the time
function you know especially like with
what each of these mean you know percent
year you know percent uppercase y
percent lowercase blah blah blah blah
blah um basically all that kind of data
that we want to get on it the other
thing that we can do just hit ctrl C to
break out of that and we've left help
the other thing we could do is if you
want to get the answer right away you
could do help and then in parentheses
time like that what what happened here
oh okay first we'll have to import time
and then we'll do help time like that
and here we have the information again
the same information we were just
looking at so the help module is just
kind of a great way to get documentation
on a module that maybe you're not too
familiar with so definitely check that
out if you're working with a module and
you're maybe thinking that you want to
do something or you don't know anything
about that module
or maybe looking for something specific
or you just want to learn a little bit
more about it check out the built-in
help function the next thing I want to
cover here is maximum and minimum um I
suppose we can continue on in this
interactive interpreter I just don't
like that it's always at the bottom
maybe I'll scroll it up here okay since
these are built-in functions what's the
it's not a big deal to work with this so
let's say example list equals then we're
going to just do
this so that's our example this so it's
just a string of numbers you can
immediately find the minimum and the
maximum of this list by doing the
following so X actually let's just print
it out so print a max and then X list
and that will print the maximum number
so 8 and then conversely if you're not
familiar if you wanna if you're in the
interactive interpreter and you want to
get the last line again you can hold alt
press P and that brings up what you
previously had and you can just come
over here let's just change this to
minimum hit enter and our if we find our
minimum to be 0 okay that makes a whole
lot of sense now um so that's Max and
min I use those pretty often the next
thing that we want to cover here is
rounding you can round numbers so we
could say x equals 5 point 6 to 2 and
then print we can pray round X like that
and that will obviously round up
conversely say X was not five point six
to two but five point two to two and
then we did print round X we get five so
it rounds up and down I'm not going to
show them here but there's also you can
use you can import math in the math dot
seal five point six six for example I
guess we can do it real quick
it's gonna want I've used this but I'm
pretty sure you would just do so import
math and then print math die will do a
method floor first and we'll do X I
should work for us so we get five then
you can do
texts um
seal like that and you get 6 so floor
and seal basically what they'll do is
they'll round for you up and down now
again I just want to stress this isn't a
built-in function math comes with it and
that's part of the standard library this
isn't a built-in function but I figure
while we're talking about rounding we
might as well consider ceiling and floor
so sometimes you always want to round up
sometimes you always want to round down
and so like that's how you can that's
how you can do that um but anyway again
math isn't really built in function I
just felt like that was a good time to
cover it the next thing that we can do
is converting data types around so we
can do all sorts of things so for
example we can say int me equals a 55
like that
so in me is a string but we could
convert that let's say to a number so we
could say print int int empty parameters
but we'll fill them with int me and now
the string 55 has been converted to the
integer of 55 we could also do the same
thing and instead of converting it to an
integer we could say we want to make it
a float so it should come out of 50 5.0
sure enough we've converted it to a
float um we can also take um you know we
can say string me equals fit well we'll
do 77 and we can print the string
version of string me and it's 77 like
that um for whatever reason it's not
putting quotes around it like we want
but I promise you it is a string so
anyway as long as they can be converted
to and from each other um the you know
like you can't take hi and convert it to
a an int right so you can't say print in
hi right that's not going to work
because you can't do that it's not
convertible to an integer but as long as
it can be converted it will be converted
with some of these so I did just want to
cover that stuff so
just a quick recap through everything we
had well we started with absolute
absolute values um and just just in case
someone that's not computers is a little
curious about absolute values at least
for my my uses I use absolute values a
lot because if I'm doing percent change
for example if we go let's say we try to
calculate the percentage change from
negative 6 to or from negative 9 let's
say to negative 6 for example it's going
to call this an axe actually a negative
33 percent change even though that's not
true it was a positive 33 percent change
it's going to call it a negative so it
was not a negative movement it was a
positive movement so if you're ever
doing percent change with negatives I
use absolute value bars there's many
other reasons why you would use absolute
values as well but that's just a quick
example why I use it then we didn't help
so anytime you have a function that
maybe you don't know much about you can
use the help command pretty much with
anything within the standard Python
library you can use it on and there's
it's good information it would behoove
you to use it from time to time um then
after that converting from strings ants
all that maximum minimum rounding and
then ceiling in floor with math so
anyway that's going to conclude this
tutorial sorry if it was a little long
looks like we're about 10 minutes or 10
and a half minutes but pretty much
covered all the built in functions again
I'll put a link in the description if I
forget someone remind me I'll put in
there I like to forget to all the other
ones but then what we're going to be
doing in the next few videos is talking
about OS sis and then we'll hit URL Lib
all these really really great modules
and it's good to learn a lot about them
because you could do a lot of really
cool stuff with them so anyway stay
tuned for that
if you guys have any questions or
comments on this video feel free to
leave them below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions until next time